children are especially at risk of
distracted drivers because busy roads
are near their schools
a new study pinpoints the nation's five
worst counties for distracted drivers
they are New York Kings and Queens
counties in New York State San Francisco
County in California and miami-dade
County in Florida
researchers found 88% of drivers are
using their phones while behind the
wheel and one in three are engaged in
unsafe behaviors in a school zone car
Evans shows us the study you'll see
first on CBS this morning parents
walking their kids to this San Francisco
elementary school might not know they
were in the nation's second most
dangerous County for distracted drivers
I'm about to step and walk across the
street and I almost got run over by
somebody
Claudia Morales says she and her
daughter have had several close calls
eight-year-old Thalia thinks she knows
why a new study recently analyzed almost
four million drivers cruising near
seventy five thousand schools it
determines San Francisco's Bessie
Carmichael Elementary has some of the
most dangerous streets in the country
for distracted driving a school in
Houston has the worst drivers with
campuses in Manhattan and Dallas
rounding out the top five in general the
more urban the county the riskier the
school roads which is more dangerous the
morning drop-off her afternoon pickup
absolutely the afternoon by about 40%
Jonathan mattis is CEO of Zen Drive the
company behind the research he says the
afternoon hours from 2:00 to 5:00 p.m.
are more dangerous than the morning
especially from 4:00 to 5:00 p.m.
likely due to heavier work traffic all
his data is now collected online for
anyone to access we put all of this
information into a very powerful map
where you can search any name of any one
of the 75,000 schools as we collected
for instance if you type in the study's
top-rated school Victory Christian
School in North Carolina it will show
you it's a plus grade for average phone
use while driving that's in contrast
the Lutheran Church in Texas the area
around that school received an F armed
with the new Gaeta police can deploy
more resources in dangerous areas police
work is driven by information so if the
information showing we have to keep
addressing traffic issues and make the
streets better well that's a good thing
Matas says he hopes parents will take
any failing grades to their local school
boards in law enforcement it's their
duty to keep our kids safe and now we
can give them a scorecard and keep them
accountable and help them focus the
resources on the areas that really need
that attention for CBS this morning
Carter Evans San Francisco well that's
fascinating that's a good example of
where technology information can keep
people safe especially children but
everybody thinks they can text and drive
you think I can just send off one quick
little text but you really can't you
know I can't do it they don't realize
how far the car goes in the seconds of
apparently yeah
we'll post online where you can find
details about the school you go to
because I want to know yeah I want to
know